die frage ob ein aktuelles polizeiliches
führungszeugnis eintragung enthielte
nein ich habe es dort abgegeben bei
ihnen das zu treffen und dann frage ob
es vor der afg andere mitgliedschaften
gab nur in der jugendorganisation jetzt
die uhr in der jungen union von 1990 bis
vielen dank an haben jetzt fünf minuten
zeit für ihre vorstellung
bevor ich mit meiner vorstellung
beginnen möchte ich kurz etwas erwähnen
sollte ich heute hier zum bundesvorstand
gewählt werden welche als erstes mit
dafür sorgen dass solche leute wie hdd
und hier nie wieder auf ein parteitag
sprechen werden
[Applaus]
liebe parteifreunde ich stamme aus
weißwasser in der oberlausitz den
letzten zipfel schlesiens der heute noch
in deutschland und ich bin verheiratet
ich habe drei kinder im alter von 6 16
und 19 jahren von beruf bin ich maler
und lackierermeister ich habe bis vor
kurzem einen eigenen betrieb mit sechs
mitarbeitern geführt und habe nerlinger
ausgebildet deshalb kandidiere ich heute
für den höchsten posten unserer partei
die gründung der afg löste eine
aufbruchstimmung aus die mich bis heute
beflügelt
dieses erhebende gefühl etwas neues
aufzubauen das gut und richtig ist hier
unser land das ist der grund weshalb
hier heute stehen wir haben heute die
gelegenheit ein historisches zeichen zu
setzen eine doppelstadt bitte mit
vertretern aus west und ost einer
doppelspitze einer doppelspitze mit der
sich akademiker und nichtakademiker
identifizieren können
wir sind die erste gesamtdeutsche partei
seit der wiedervereinigung und die
wahlerfolge im osten sind auch der
verdienst unserer mitstreiter aus dem
westen das würde ich ganz klar sagen
denn ihr habt es viel schwerer am besten
ich habe es bei vielen
wahlkampfauftritten in baden württemberg
bayern und rheinland pfalz erlebt und
ihr habt trotzdem unseren wahlkampf
unterstützt und dafür danken wir euch
[Applaus]
aber
aber der osten fordert zu recht eine
starke stimme im bundesvorstand nun höre
ich manchmal es ist noch zu früh für
mich aber dann hat man immer gesagt mit
23 war ich zu jung
eine familie zu gründen mit 25 war ich
zu jung eine ausbildung zum maler
meister zu machen mit 620 bereich zu
jugend ein haus zu bauen
mit 27 war ich zu jung eine firma zu
gründen am ende hat sich aber meine
zuversicht immer durchgesetzt gegen die
stimmen der zweifler und bedenkenträger
und dafür dafür
dafür habe ich auch meiner familie
gedanken vor allem meinen eltern und
meiner frau es war immer die richtige
entscheidung
ich bin kein mann der vielen worte ich
bin ein mann der tat
seit 2007 leitet auch den kreisverband
görlitz einen der erfolgreichsten
kreisverbände in sachsen und beinahe
hätten wir sogar den ersten auf die
oberbürgermeister in einer deutschen
stadt gestellt 45 prozent haben in
görlitz meinte partei vor hinter dem
polizeioberkommissar sebastian witte
gewählt und nur
und nur an die linke einheitsfront aus
cdu spd linke und grünen konnte das
verhindern und an herrn söder anziehen
und die anderen möchtegern konservativen
werden mit der gewalttätigen angriff
fahren görlitz auf die straße gehen wie
die cdu ist mit sicherheit nicht
konservativ
[Applaus]
in der bundestagswahl 2017 habe ich das
direktmandat im landkreis görlitz mit 32
5 prozent gewonnen und den amtierenden
ministerpräsidenten von sachsen vom
platz gejagt
[Applaus]
als vorstandsmitglied in der
bundestagsfraktion habe ich noch fast
aus dem nichts heraus die fraktions
finanzen geordnet und ihr könnt euch
sicher vorstellen dass das kein
zuckerschlecken war das größte
wählerpotenzial sehe ich im bürgerlich
konservativen lager bei den menschen die
keine politische heimat mehr haben weil
die konservativen parteien
sie verraten haben bei den menschen die
im dunkeln auf den unter arbeit fahren
im dunkeln wieder nach hause kommen bei
den menschen die es satt haben ihren
gürtel immer enger zu schnallen
weil sie schon fast nicht mehr atmen
können und bei den handwerkern und
mittelständischen unternehmen die
ausgepresst werden wie eine zitrone und
die bürgerliche mitte die bürgerliche
mitte erreichen wir mit vernunft nur mit
überzeugenden inhalten werden hier neue
wählerschichten erschließen
dazu braucht ist keine drastische
sprache denn unsere forderungen nach
sicheren grenzen und einer
heimatverbundenen politik sind nicht
extrem
sie sind extrem vernünftig und mit
drastischer sprache
bedrückt man häufig das gegenteil vor
allem bei den frauen
doch die die uns den rücken stärken vor
allem die ehefrauen schwestern mütter
und großmütter viele frauen fielen im
grunde ihres herzens konservativ weil
sie eine lebenswerte zukunft für ihre
kinder ende können wir wollen wir wollen
die idee zur verfügung ich dir bereit
zum wohl unserer partei und zum wohl und
als deutschen vaterlandes er sei kein
mann der vielen worte sondern ein mann
der taten fiat uno kubala in seiner
bewerbungsrede für den posten des
zweiten bundessprecher der ft und einige
leute menschen stehen hier auf um zu
applaudieren unter anderem sehen wir
auch alexander gauland mehr tricks von
storch die ebenfalls aufgestanden sind
so es wegen fragen vor und die
reihenfolge der fragesteller die losen
wir jetzt hier wie gewohnt aus die erste
frage kommt von
frankreich
die zweite frage von wolfgang mader und
die dritte frage von lothar mehlhose
frankreich am blauen saal mikrofon eine
halbe minute zeit bin ich ja mein name
ist von kral
ich habe über ein jahr lang die
finanzabteilung der bundestagsfraktionen
geleitet herr pofalla sie behaupten sie
hätten die finanzen aus nichts in
ordnung gebracht da gab's nix in ordnung
zu bringen weil alles in ordnung war
wie können sie sich erdreisten hierhin
zu stehen maßnahmen zu beschließen die
viel geld gekostet haben und unterm
strich nichts gebracht haben da gab es
nichts zu ordnen was haben sie geordnet
dankeschön zur antwort
also hat sie sich am 30 diese frage zu
stellen
das ist eigentlich eher der witz das ist
der punkt 1 der punkt zwei die maßnahmen
die wir zu dieser situation die wir
getroffen haben auch passen mussten die
habe ich nicht alleine getroffen hat der
fraktionsvorstand getroffen und auch die
fraktion und ich habe als ich die finanz
mit meinem team übernommen haben einen
desaströsen haufen vorgenommen und
vorgesehen und wenn ich muss ich ihnen
ganz ehrlich sagen was unsere team vor
allem auch die mitarbeiter in der
bundestagsfraktion im bereich finanzen
das letzte jahr geleistet haben das ist
aller ehren wert
das hat unsere fraktion und auch unsere
partei gerettet
vielen dank die zweite frage von
wolfgang mader im roten saal mikrofon
eine halbe minute zeit für die frage
herr kubala die fdp ist die einzige
partei in deutschland die die existenz
israels sichert warum haben sie bei dem
einen fdp-antrag sich der stimme
enthalten zur sicherung in israel zur
antwort das kann ich ihnen genau sagen
es war ich habe mir diese diesen bds
antrag den sie jetzt meinen genau
angucken ich habe mich dort enthalten
übrigens den anderen parteien haben
dagegen bestimmt das will ich als erstes
mal sagen ich habe mich deswegen
enthalten weil genau diese besetzung der
palästinischen palästinensischen gebiete
laut un-resolution völkerrechtswidrig
sind und deswegen konnte ich mich nicht
entscheiden
pro oder contra zu stimmt aber ich will
es ganz klar sagen ich stelle hier nicht
das existenzrecht israels infrage
ganz eindeutig nicht danke schön wie
dritte frage kommt von waterman rose am
blauen vor mikrofonen bitteschön als
allererstes bitte ich meine stunde zu
entschuldigen der kubaner sie haben eben
sehr schön ausgeführt dass sie über
keine akademische vorbildung verfügen
was ich persönlich sehr sympathisch
finde aber es gibt schon
parteimitglieder die das kritisch sehen
was sagen sie diesen verantwortung ja es
gibt immer parteien mitglieder die zu
jeder person was kritisch sehen haben
wir heute gehört ich sage ihnen ganz
ehrlich ich schaue auch ein bisschen auf
die auf unser wählerpotenzial vereinen
auf die person die uns werden welche
wählerschichten wählen uns denn und ich
finde es wir haben heute das habe ich in
meiner rede gesagt die einmalige chance
repräsentanten akademiker und nicht
akademiker an die spitze einer partei zu
stellen
handwerksmeister die im prinzip hier
für unser land jeden tag arbeiten müssen
und vor allem als konservativ
bürgerlichen partei irgendwie mit guten
beispiel vorangehen denn das gibt es in
deutschland in keiner anderen partei das
in den spitzen du ein akademiker und ein
handwerksmeister hier die führung
übernehmen das hätte unsere partei sehr
gut
[Applaus]